كان يُعتقد أن هذه الفراشة
انقرضت على الرغم من إعادة اكتشافها ، إلا أنها تظل
واحدة من أندر الفراشات وأكثرها مراوغة في العالم ،
هذه هي
الفراشة الزرقاء بالوس فيرديس ، هذه الفراشة
بعيدة المنال بقدر ما هي جميلة ولا يظهر
تألق أجنحتها الزرقاء إلا
عندما تفتح  الأجنحة
مميزة بلونها الأزرق الفضي اللامع
، وكان يُعتقد أن الفراشة
قد انقرضت في الثمانينيات عندما بدت وكأنها
تختفي دون أن تترك أثرًا ، فلم
يتم اكتشاف هذه
الفراشة المذهلة مرة أخرى حتى التسعينيات.
[موسيقى]
فوجئ علماء الأحياء بذلك
وسعدت بوجودها وبدأ برنامج تربية
لبناء الأنواع على الرغم من أن
التربية الأسيرة ساعدت في تعزيز
أعداد السكان لا تزال منخفضة
بما يكفي للبقاء على القائمة المهددة بالانقراض من
خلال رعاية وإدارة حذرة
لهذه الفراشة الصغيرة ولكن القوية لديها
فرصة قتالية هذا  is the palos verdes
blue butterfly
[موسيقى]